CHRISTINA RIEHL: My
name is Christie Riehl,
and I'm an assistant professor
in the Department of Ecology
and Evolutionary
Biology at Princeton,
and my research focus
is on animal behavior
and behavioral ecology.
My main study system
is the greater ani.
They are a bird that
breeds cooperatively.
So unlike most birds, where a
male and female build a nest
and share parental care
of their nestlings,
anis breed in groups
where several pairs build
one nest together and all of
the individuals in the group
reproduce.
The females lay their eggs
in the nest, more or less
synchronously.
And they share parental care
of the mixed clutch of young.
But the females also
compete with each other.
And the way they do this
is before each female lays
her own first egg, if
she goes to the nest then
she hasn't laid yet,
and sees an egg in the nest
that anther female in the group
has laid, she'll push
that egg out of the nest.
I was able to film this
behavior for the first time two
years ago.
And we've been trying
actually for a couple of years
to get this behavior on film.
And when I saw it
for the first time,
it was really a
special moment for me
because it was a behavior
I had studied for years.
I knew that this egg
ejection happened
and I knew it was
an important fitness
cost to females in the group.
But I didn't know what it
looks like or how they did it.
Anis are very unusual among
cooperatively breeding birds
because the adults that form
these reproductive groups
together are not genetically
related to one another.
They're not family members.
In most cooperatively
breeding birds,
one of the benefits
of cooperation
is through kin selection that
you help pass on your genes
by helping relatives that
also carry your identical gene
copies because you had
a parent or an uncle
or another relative in common.
And anis don't have those kin
selected or indirect fitness
benefits.
There are very strong direct
benefits to breeding in groups.
So what I found
in my Ph.D. work was
that the probability that a
group will escape predation
and successfully fled young
is related to group size.
So the larger the group you're
in, the more likely you are to
fled young successfully
from the nest.
Predation is very high in
tropical birds in general
and in Panama about
70% of ani nests
are predated mostly by snakes.
I got interested in biology
solely through birds.
I've always loved birds.
And when I was about 11 or
12, I was an avid bird watcher
and I still am.
So the thing I wanted to
do more than anything
was just go outside
with binoculars
and identify all the
bird species I could see
and I still love doing that.
I think one of the things that's
most special about Princeton
is the independence it affords
its researchers and the amount
of interaction
between researchers
and graduate students
and colleagues.
It's a kind of place where
you can work with undergraduates
and help them design their
senior thesis projects
on a topic that interests them.
Graduate students have
a lot of independence.
They are not
constrained by working
on their advisers'
grants, for example.
So I think it's a place where
the community and the resources
make a lot of exciting
research possible.